she really missed yeah it's really a
one-of-a-kind actress yeah i still
remember the the snickers commercials
during super bowl she did remember those
those were great good to see you and we
were actually in vegas and we were
actually talking about how she had a
great voice i'm surprised she didn't
keep singing yeah right that's good that
she's up there with the golden girls now
right yeah
gusty wins for tonight now we've talked
about these wins we've had wins before
obviously christian during new year's
eve but what you really want to remember
when you're with those when you're out
there with these wins is the windchill
okay
even though you're bundled up you really
want to bundle up with these winds that
are really going to be blowing in here
and peaking in the next few hours live
look outside at the las vegas strip the
calm before the storm here's a look at
our weather alerts the wind winter
weather advisory earlier was cancel so
nothing here hard freeze warning for you
in kingman that begins tomorrow and
that's because your temperatures are
going to drop to the 20s by sunday
morning almanac 58 degrees the official
high for the day today just a couple
digits above normal 74 our record on the
state that was back in 1995. currently
outside let's start off with the
northwest part of the valley current we
uh it's 52 degrees for centennia hills
and providence 47 for someone 55 for
downtown north las vegas we could use 60
degrees on the east side there sunrise
manor 59 for green valley
southern highlands 57 got a lot of views
in seven hills you're 52 and 53 for
henderson right now 49 currently for
prim 50 even for boulder city 57 for la
flip so valley radar dry right now
getting a couple of snowflakes up there
on the sheep range you see those low
clouds to the north that's what we're
seeing right now this is traversing from
west to or i should say from west to
east and away from us right now but what
are the chances of getting some rain
drops tonight the possibility is out
there but according to our futurecast if
anything happens it's really going to be
before 9 00 pm all right and if anything
pops up it'll be mainly light showers or
light sprinkles very isolated or nothing
at all we call that virgo as it
evaporates before it reaches the ground
this is all going to be before 9 pm
later on tonight the skies clear out but
this is what we got to watch right those
gusty winds will be up to 30 at times
maybe exceeding that throughout the
evening as that cold front starts to
push its way into the valley as it
passes through we'll get those winds
down to 25 and the colder temperatures
come behind that new year's eve 37
degrees will be your low gusty and cold
for tonight your wind chill in the
morning will feel more like 28 degrees
isolated sprinkles this evening are
possible 46 for tomorrow for new year's
day and that's it that's all we could
get cold front passes through leaves
behind colder air so chilly and breezy
tomorrow the wind chill in the afternoon
is going to feel more like 41 degrees
with those gusts here's your recreation
forecast 29 degrees wind chill at -15
or i should say 15 degrees actually for
mount charleston for tomorrow with those
winds 49 for lake mead chilly and gusty
with high waves we could see possible
wind advisories for tomorrow so here's
your eight day forecast after those cold
mornings we're going to have on sunday
and monday look at that below freezing
next week gets warmer in those low 60s
for the towards the end of the week
don't forget to follow me on social
media as i will be tweeting those wind
speeds throughout the evening in the
meantime have a safe night christian
centuri